welcome to this no black box machine
learning course in JavaScript
you will gain a deep understanding of
machine learning systems by coding
without relying on libraries this unique
approach that only demystifies the inner
workings of machine learning but also
significantly enhances software
development skills the course is
designed and taught by Radu who has a
PHD in computer science and is a
university lecturer from building a
drawing app and working with data to
exploring feature extraction and
implementing various classifiers this
course covers a wide array of topics
that will equip you with the knowledge
and expertise to create your own machine
learning driven applications hi and
welcome to the no black box machine
learning course in JavaScript it's a
course where we code without using
libraries because it's the best way to
learn all linear workings in a machine
Learning System and you'll greatly
improve your software development skills
as well
actually the course is a lot about
software engineering especially in the
beginning and the focus slowly shifts
towards machine learning as it goes on
our main goal is to build a web app that
learns to recognize drawings if you've
seen Quick Draw from Google it's
something like that with a few key
differences I'll point out along the way
for machine learning we need data so
I'll first teach you how to build the
data collection tool it's a drawing app
that works on desktop and mobile devices
we'll later reuse the sketchpad
component to build a recognizer as well
next I'll teach you how to process and
visualize the data collected with the
tool the drawings you made when asked
for help if you missed that video and
want your drawings to be used at some
point it's not too late to do it now
then we move on to feature extraction
and visualization we built this chart
component from scratch it's a relatively
big project but worth it because
building it we practice much of the same
math we later need for machine learning
we also customize it so much it becomes
an essential teaching tool for what
follows
speaking of which this is where most
machine learning courses typically start
they use some existing data and features
famous data sets that are publicly
available and that's okay it helps dive
into things much quicker but I include
this part because in my experience it's
never that easy in real life being able
to collect data visualize it clean it
and shape it in a useful form are all
really important steps you need to do in
practice and not understanding data well
is why people fail at machine learning
even the most sophisticated libraries
fail if the data is not what you expect
but this is our data you made part of it
so I'm pretty sure we won't have that
problem
now the simplest learning method I can
think of is the nearest neighbor
classifier I'll teach you how to
implement it and integrate it with the
sketch pad so it recognizes what we draw
it will work okay-ish it's a simple
method but it can work even better if we
apply data scaling a step everybody
performs when doing machine learning but
very few people can explain why at least
from what I've seen I'll make sure you
understand why it helps
we then implement the more advanced K
nearest neighbors classifier and
calculate its accuracy for different
values of K
to understand things even better I'll
teach you how to compute decision
boundaries and display them on our chart
now at work I teach a version of this
course in python and a poll I made
recently shows that some of you are
interested in that as well so the last
lesson will be a review where we do the
same things in Python spoiler alert I'll
use libraries and it will be over quite
fast
now when I said last lesson I mean that
of phase one this is when the course
will take a short break it will give you
enough time to focus on the homework
sorry but if you really want to learn
following recipe videos like this is
just not enough
but don't worry they're not that hard
high school math and some programming
experience is all you need if you need
to brush up on those these videos here
can help and if you get really stuck
join my Discord where me and other
students can help
we then begin phase two where we learn
more advanced methods like these
I actually got a pretty good accuracy
using the same neural network we coded
in the self-driving car course there
might be some kind of crossover
happening
let's see
let me show you how to build a drawing
app for data collection it will ask for
some information first and then tell you
what you need to draw this sketchpad
also has undo and save functionalities
and it works on desktop and mobile
devices as well
we'll Implement everything in this
course using visual studio code and to
test we'll use a web browser
today we build a web application so
let's begin by creating a new folder
called web and inside this folder we'll
create our first file
Creator dot HTML
it will be a web page that we use to
create data for our data set
now we begin to type basic HTML
and
in the head I will give this page a
title
let's call it data creator
and let's link an external style sheet a
CSS file that we will have to implement
this will hold all the styles that we
need in this project
let's close the head section
and Define a body
where I'm going to have a div with an ID
of content that will hold everything
we'll Implement today
and that will include a title section
this data Creator using an H1 tag
and let's have a line break
and then a div with ID sketchpad
container we'll implement the sketch pad
today and this container is going to
hold it
let's close our content div
and our body
and the HTML so save the file and now
let's open the file in the browser and
we get this the only thing we see in the
page is this H1 tag from here because
this line break and this container are
invisible for now we also get an error
in the console here I have the browser
developer tools open and I recommend you
do the same the error here just means
that we don't have the Styles CSS file
existing yet let's create it by going
here and typing Styles dot CSS and
inside I'm going to add basic styles for
the page
for the body I'm going to set the font
family to Ariel
and the background color will be sky
blue
I will also add some styles for this
content I want it to be in the middle of
the page always so the position will be
absolute and I'm gonna give it 50 from
the top and 50 from the left but this
will make the top left corner of the
content be in the middle of the page so
I want it to go half its width and half
its height to the left and towards the
top so I'm going to right here transform
translate minus 50 minus 50 percent
and text align to Sender
if I refresh this
I'm going to get data Creator exactly in
the middle of the page the background is
blue and aerial font let's begin to
implement our sketch pad
so we'll do that in an external
Javascript file and we'll load this at
the end of the body here
so it will be in a folder called JS for
JavaScript and we'll call it
sketchpad.js let's close the script tag
and here we are going to instantiate our
sketch pad in another script tag and we
will Define it to be on the sketchpad
container like this
let's close the script tag now
and Define this file so first the JS
folder I'm going to create a folder
called Js
and inside of this folder I'm going to
create
sketch pad
dot JS make sure that it's really inside
of the JS folder and not in the same
line with the other ones and here we
will use the class syntax so let's
define our sketch pad class
and the Constructor will have
a container in this case our div from
earlier and the size let's say 400 by
default
to implement the sketch pad we'll use an
HTML canvas element and I will create it
here as an attribute of this class
by calling document create element
canvas like this
I will set the width of this canvas to
be the size and the height of this
canvas to be the size as well and let's
give it also a little bit of style I
will write this canvas dot style is
equal to and now I'm going to open a
backtick to write a template literal a
string that works on multiple lines
and let's write here a background color
of white
and the Box shadow
with these properties
black
I will close the back tick here and the
semicolon so notice here this backtick
don't confuse it with the single quote
it won't work on multiple lines like
this now let's go here and append
this canvas to The Container to the div
and we can save the file refresh the
page and here it is our future sketch
pad to draw on this canvas we are going
to use the canvas context the 2D context
which we get like this and I'm storing
it here in this CTX attribute of the
sketch pad
and we will have to add event listeners
to detect the mouse actions
I will do this using a private method
add event listener here like this so we
will have to implement this method next
I will do it down here and it's a
private method it has this hashtag in
front it means that it cannot be called
from outside this class
and the first thing that we will do is
add to our canvas and unmouse down event
listener like this
we will detect the unmouse down action
and we will figure out the coordinates
we will do this by first getting the
rectangle
of the canvas bounding area
with this function
and then we will
obtain the mouse coordinates by taking
the client X of this event minus the
left side of this rectangle so in this
way we get an x coordinate that is
relative to the left side of the canvas
and the same thing for the y-coordinate
relative to the top part of the canvas
this is 0 0. now notice here for Mouse
I'm using an array syntax so this will
correspond to x coordinate and this will
correspond to y coordinate we will be
using this syntax everywhere because at
some point we will start working with
higher dimensions and in this way we
don't run out of letters to use
now let's lock this mouse location
and see if this code Works save the file
refresh the page
and if I'm going to click
we can get here the coordinates every
time I click I see different coordinates
closer to the top left corner we get
coordinates very close to zero closer to
the bottom right corner we get
coordinates close to 400 400 how we
specified here the size to be now these
are floating Point numbers with
incredibly High Precision we won't need
any of that and integers are enough
so I'm just going to go here and
add a rounding to these values so let's
just say math
round like this
and let's close this parenthesis as well
refresh
and now when we are clicking we get
these integer values that are easier to
work with let's remove this debugging
and start creating our path that we draw
on the sketch pad
so I will say here this path
is an array that contains the mouse when
we just click on the canvas that's what
we get one point added into this path
array and I will also Mark here that the
drawing has started like this these will
be attributes of the class let me go up
here and Define them
his drawing is set to false by default
and the path is empty now we are going
to do the same thing here but for on a
mouse move another event listener
I'm just going to copy everything and
replace here unmouse down with on Mouse
move
like this
and we will process this only if we are
drawing so we will be moving on top of
the mouse all the time but only if we
are drawing so only if is drawing
then
we do something here
and we get the coordinates of the mouse
same as last time but here we add it to
the path so we write here
dot push
this mouse location
and we know that is drawing is true
otherwise we wouldn't be here so let's
just remove this line and the log here
the length of our path
let's also add an event listener here
for on Mouse
up and the only thing that we do here
is set is drawing to false again and we
don't actually need this parameter here
anymore we don't care where the mouse is
up because the path has been modified
with the last Mouse move
so I'm going to save this
refresh and now when I click and the
drag
the number that you see there is the
number of points that have been added to
the path that I'm drawing we can't see
the path just yet but you can see it
growing every time I'm moving the mouse
and if I release the mouse now I
released the mouse and if I'm going to
press it again and start dragging I
create
A New Path again
what happens is that here path is
re-initialized with just the mouse
location on Mouse down now before we
continue part of this code here needs to
be fixed like this is essentially the
same thing as this let me just remove
this part from here and extract a
function for getting this mouse location
so it will be a private function let's
call it get mouse
given
an event parameter
I'm going to paste here this code
and start to align it
and here we can just return directly
these coordinates
like so
now this get mouse function
we can write it here as
Mouse is equal to this dot get mouse
with the event parameter and I can copy
this
for the top part here as well
let's refresh
and the same functionality as before
but now the code is much easier to read
than simpler
all we need to do now is draw on the
canvas instead of logging these numbers
here
so let me write here this redraw this
will redraw everything on the canvas
it's a method that we'll Implement next
and I'm going to write it here like so
we will start with clearing the canvas
using the clear rect method starting at
0 0 the top left corner and going all
the way to Canvas width and canvas
height
and then we are going to draw our path
for that I'm going to implement a draw
utility object it will have
a function called path
that we can specify here the context and
this path the one that we want to draw
now let's create this draw utility
object inside of its own file I'm just
going to import it here first it's going
to be called
draw and let's create it in the
JavaScript folder so inside of the
JavaScript folder here we create draw.js
and we initialize our object called draw
like this and let's add the path
function to it
is going to have a context
a path and a default caller set to Black
so the stroke style is going to be set
to the given color black in this case
and let's set here a line with maybe
three
We Begin The Path
and now we're going to move to the first
point in the path now this move 2
typically has two parameters but this
path of zero has the X Y inside of an
array and this syntax here spreads that
array out into its two components so we
can call this move to just specifying
one item here and then we will iterate
from one all the way to the path length
like this and do a line to
the same syntax with path of I like this
and then we stroke
let's save this
refresh
and now you can see the line appearing
there
and if I release the mouse and click
again
it starts again actually so it's not
good we would like to draw multiple
paths but it's something and before we
get to multiple paths there is one thing
that I don't like very much maybe I can
show you if I zoom in
um
can you see when drawing there are some
Corners appearing
when I change suddenly Direction
I'm not sure if you
can notice what I mean but for example
this corner this corner this corner they
appeared out of the blue somehow and
this is because of how the line join is
done and also the line cap this ending
here that is
straight I would like it to be more
round it looks better like that
so we can change these things
like so
save this refresh and now the line cap
is round and when we change direction
like that we also have a round Corner
Point here so those problems don't
happen anymore
let me Zoom back out
okay to draw multiple paths I'm going to
generate here a new function
again a context paths this time and then
again a default color set to Black
and what we will do is go through all
the paths
and for each path we draw path
with these properties so what we do here
is reuse this other function from above
to draw multiple paths instead and in
the sketch pad
we are going to go up and rename this
path to paths now this will be an array
of arrays
and here we are going to say path
dot push
an array containing
one point
and here where we want to add the points
to the path we now want to add the point
to the last path
so let's get the last path first
it's going to be the last one in this
paths array
like this
and then we are going to push the mouse
into this last path
and our redraw method
is going to call draw paths
this time with paths
let's save this refresh
and there is an error here
because I forgot to change this path
into a paths as well I should have used
this right click rename symbol feature
to rename it everywhere in that way you
don't make such mistakes
now refresh
okay but it's not yet perfect if I'm
going to press this button here
this is how it would look like on a
mobile device and this is just not not
great
to fix this I can go to Creator HTML
and here at the top in the head section
I'm going to say
meta name equals to viewport it's a
viewport meta tag
with the content equal to width equals
device width like this
I'm going to save this refresh and
notice how the width has changed here at
the top you can choose multiple devices
if you want to try them out but this one
has a width of 375 and my canvas here is
a little bit too large
so you can actually fix this by
specifying here
coma and then
maximum scale something like 0.9 in this
case it's going to rescale everything a
little bit downwards to 90 percent and
my canvas fits even on these smaller
screens
now we don't want users to zoom in and
out on this page and we can prevent that
by going here and specifying user
scalable
zero but there is a big problem here
this sketch pad just doesn't work I'm
trying to draw now and it doesn't work
and the reason for that is that the
event listeners for the touch are
different than the event listeners for
the mouse so we are going to go to our
sketch pad to add event listeners and
here I'm going to write
untouched start
a new event listener I'm going to get
the location from the event touches
and I'm going to just call on Mouse down
with this so the same code from here we
reuse it but we get it from the first
touch because multi-touch is also
possible on devices like this
now we do the same thing here
for untouch move
and the same here
for untouched end
now if I'm going to save this
refresh
it works also in this
mobile device mode
but some people have mentioned to me
that it sometimes doesn't work on Apple
devices and when you try to draw it
moves the page up and down I'm not sure
if this entirely fixes the problem but
you can go to the body and say here
over scroll Behavior
to none if somebody else knows how to
make it even better than this please let
me know
let's save this and I'm going to exit
now from this mode Let's Implement undo
functionality
I'm going to go back to the sketch pad
in the top here
after we add this to the container
I will add few more things
first a line break
and after that a button
an undo button
with an inner HTML set to undo
and let's append both of these
to our container
let's save this and refresh and you can
see the undo button now here let's add
an event listener to it I'm gonna go
here at the end of this function and say
undo BTN on click
and we are going to pop from our paths
and redraw everything
refresh draw some things undo
and it works but we shouldn't be able to
undo things
after this is empty so I'm going to go
here at the end of redraw and I will
toggle the undo functionality so if this
path's length
is greater than zero
this undo button
is going to be enabled
otherwise
undo button
is going to be disabled
now if I'm going to refresh this
and undo two times this is a disabled
button here we can make it look nicer if
we go to Styles I'm just going to add
the general style for buttons and say
I want the cursor to be pointer now it's
the default cursor that looks like an
arrow but the pointer is that kind of
hand symbol and I like that over buttons
let's remove the board there set the
padding
and a little bit bigger height
border radius make it a little bit curvy
and a dark blue color let's use navy and
a white color for the text we are also
going to add a different color for the
hover state
I'm going to set background color to
medium blue
and let's add the styles for the
disabled State and also the disabled
State on Hover
both of them are required
and I will make this gray and then we
can put the default cursor here
save this
refresh
and now the button looks a little bit
nicer and when it's disabled it looks
like this and the cursor also changes
now if I refresh this the undo should be
disabled here
so I'm actually going to go to the
sketch pad and call this redraw here in
the beginning
it's going to handle that as well
and it becomes enabled as I'm drawing
something
now let's proceed to add the
functionality that we need to create a
data set we have to record who the
person is and to have a button to
advance to the next drawing
I'm going to go here to Creator and
actually we also need to
make the sketchpad invisible at the
beginning while we ask the people who
they are so let's start with that I'm
going to go here and say
style visibility is hidden in the
beginning
let me just put this div on a new line
there and up here I'm going to start to
Define
the other objects that we need an input
field
I will call it student it will be a
text input field and let's have a
placeholder here type your name
like so so I'm calling it student
because I sent this to my students to
fill in
and a button
to advance to another object
and on click let's set this to start it
will have a text just saying start in
the beginning but we will change that
soon you'll see
now let's close this div save the file
refresh the page and now the sketch pad
is invisible and we can type in here and
if we press start nothing happens
because this start function doesn't
exist yet there is one thing that we
should consider at this stage though and
that is here in the head section let's
define another meta tag for the charge
set and say it should be utf-8
many people have names that have special
characters and also some people use
emojis here as their name and this will
support that now let's start to collect
the data from those fields I'm going to
go here and write data an object with
three Fields the student which is no by
default I'm also going to have a field
for the session and this is going to be
a unique identifier I'm going to use the
date and get time
for the session and I'm also going to
have an object here for the drawings
this is where we will store all the
paths that people are drawing for each
of the different drawings that we ask
them to do
now because my system is online and
several students could theoretically be
drawing at the same time I have a more
complex code on the back end to make
sure session IDs are unique but so far
this hasn't been useful all timestamps
are unique and it's not a big surprise
really given they have millisecond
precision so I won't go into more
details here and keep it simple like
this with just the timestamps
so let's Implement our start function
next I will do it here at the bottom
and say start
and check if there is a value provided
in the student field this input field
from above if it's empty I'm going to
say please type your name first
an alert
and I will return
otherwise the code will continue here
below and I will set the student from
the data to be the value from this field
I will also make this input field
disappear like this and I will make the
sketch pad appear
like this
refresh and if I press start I'm getting
this alert here
if I fill in this first and press start
I start to see the sketch pad
but this should be something else here
so let's see what things we need to draw
I'm gonna go up here and start by
defining an index
which thing I'm going to draw from a
list and this list is gonna have the
labels
Car Fish House tree
bicycle guitar pencil
and clock
like this
we will have another field up here for
instructions and I'm just going to use a
span for this with ID instructions
like so
and at the end of the start function
here I'm going to do a few things I will
get the label of the thing that we will
draw first
like this and I will set the
instructions inner HTML to be please
draw a
label
and then
we'll also modify the inner HTML of the
advanced button from start to next
I will also change the on click event on
the button to next and this is going to
be a new function that we will Implement
here
what we do inside it is we increase the
index
and we are going to copy the same things
from here
we are going to get another label and we
are going to update the instructions
like this now before we increase this
index we are going to go up here and try
to get the paths that were drawn using
the sketch pad
so if there are paths
if there are no paths we Warn and say
draw something first
and return so the code doesn't go
further but if it goes here we can get
the label of the path that was drawn so
still this index
uh-huh and here we can store in the data
add the drawings of the given label the
paths coming from the sketch pad like
this
and the sketch pad will also need the
function to reset itself to empty the
paths and redraw everything
so let's implement this too but before
that this is a problem here uh
re-defining this label this is going to
be the next label
and I'm going to copy it here as well
now in our sketch pad
I'm going to implement here our reset
method which is a public method we are
accessing it from outside and this is
just going to do
these things here actually
so I'm going to move them inside and
let's call reset here
this dot reset so this should still work
let's refresh type something here
start
please draw a car and let's Draw
Something
next please draw a fish and let's look
at our data so in the console here I'm
going to type data and we have collected
student
ASD that's the name I entered then
session and then the drawings so far
only the car has two paths one with 53
points and another 27 points
you can watch these individual points if
you want but I believe this works
now there is a problem if I'm going to
go all the way to the end we don't have
functionality for that
so the clock is the last one and then
please draw an undefined
so let's go back to Creator HTML here
and here we are going to update the
instructions only
if possible so if the index is less than
the labels length then we do that
otherwise we are pretty much done so we
say else
sketch pad container
visibility hidden we hide it
maybe we are polite and we change this
to thank you
and the button is going to turn to say
save
this is because we are going to save
whatever paths we have drawn locally in
the original version this was done on my
server but here I want you to be able to
save these files on your local computer
and the new function on click will be
called save let's implement this
function as well
so what we do here is we completely hide
the button that
says save
and the instructions are going to say
what to do with the file that you will
download
take your downloaded file place it
alongside
the others
in the data set
this will make more sense after the next
lecture
Now to create and download the file from
the browser we can make an element here
an a element
and we can set the href attribute
to data plain text with this utf-8
charge set because we may have some
utf-8 characters there and then we will
encode URI component using the
stringified version of the data so we
have to convert this into a string and
we will use Json to stringify the state
so the data that we are collecting the
paths that people are drawing are going
to be saved as a Json string in a file
Json stands for JavaScript object
notation a standard format for storing
data like what we have here it's humanly
readable and most programming languages
have support for it as well like
JavaScript
the in JavaScript we use Json stringify
to convert data into a Json string and
Json parse to convert the Json string
back into an object
now we are going to give a name to this
file and I want to give the name of the
session a unique name
that we generated from the timestamp
and now we are going to set the
attribute to download to this a element
and here specify the file name as well
and finally we need to trigger this
download action
so let me first make this element
invisible because I'm going to add it to
the body
of our document
I'm going to trigger The Click
and then I'm going to quickly remove it
from the document I just don't know of a
better way of doing this if you know let
me know
and this is our save functionality
let me save this
refresh
type a name here
start
and then car
yeah I'm not going to do it now I
already did it a while ago
now house
three
bicycle
I know some of you guys are much better
artists than I am
guitar pencil
and the clock
and now thank you save and when we press
save
we get the file here
one small thing that I still want to
show you is if I'm going to type here
the name and access this sketch pad if I
draw here it works fine but if I'm going
to move out of the page
release and go back in the page this
mouse up didn't trigger because it's
done on the canvas and sometimes you
might want that to happen
I mean for example if you want to draw
uh maybe a line like a horizon and then
your line just continues there it's not
a nice user experience
so to fix that you can go to the sketch
pad and the event listener that you're
going to add for on Mouse up is going to
be on the document instead
like this
and we have to do the same thing for the
untouched end event
like this
refresh
go here release the mouse
and then go back in the unmouse up has
triggered and now we can start to draw A
New Path
it would be nice to know if this system
works on all devices and I'd be grateful
if you test it for me there's a
spreadsheet in the description where you
can fill in the device name operating
system browser version and report if
anything is wrong great if you propose
Solutions as well
the data I collected from you is just a
bunch of Json files like the one we saw
earlier each of these contains the
session ID student name and eight
different drawings at the moment there
are about 500 files and you can get them
from GitHub the number is still growing
and I'll be updating it from time to
time
now the drawings are grouped together by
the session and that's not convenient in
the long run so I'll teach you how to
process this raw data into a more
manageable form a data set where each
drawing is a sample I'll also teach you
how to make a data visualizer app but
the processing part we do at first
doesn't really need an interface so I'll
be working with node.js a back-end
environment for JavaScript to follow
along install node.js from the link in
the description
to test if we have node.js installed
properly we're going to use a terminal
you can use the one here in Visual
Studio code if you want but I'm
old-fashioned and I use command prompt
in Windows
we can type node minus minus version and
you should see it's displayed there like
so
we are going to be working more with the
terminal today and we have to navigate
to where our project is
so this is where we built the drawing
app last time and I'm going to go to
this directory here by copying the path
and here typing
CD space and right click pastes it for
me
and now we're in the same directory if I
type here there we can see the web
directory right here
to work with the data we need a place to
store it and I'm going to create here a
directory make their data
and you can see it appearing here in
Visual Studio code as well
if you like more working with the user
interface that's also possible at this
point so this is the folder we just
created
inside it we are going to create a new
folder
called Raw
this is going to contain the raw
information collected from the drawing
app
I'm gonna go inside it and paste all the
data I've collected from students over
the past few months there are almost 500
submissions each with 8 different
drawings it's really amazing
now each of these files contain eight
drawings and we're gonna process these
to create a data set where each sample
is a drawing
I'll go back to the data directory here
and create a new folder called data set
and inside of this dataset folder I'm
going to create two different folders
one will hold the Json representation of
our samples and the other one will be in
image form
I want to visualize them as well
so a folder for Json
and the folder
for image
we'll do this processing using nodejs
and I'm going to create a directory here
using the terminal
node
and move into this directory using CD
in this directory we'll create our first
script
let's call it
data set generator
dot JS it's a Javascript file and in it
I'm going to Define some constants
in an object called constants I will
write down the paths of all the folders
We have created so far
so we have the data directory
we have the raw data directory
inside of the data directory
we have the data set directory
also inside of the data directory
and we have the Json directory
in the data set directory this time
and the image directory
also in the data set directory and here
in the data set directory I also want to
create a file where we'll store a kind
of summary for the samples
let's call this samples
it's going to be in the data set
directory and it's going to be a Json
file
samples.json like this we're going to
create this file next
I'm gonna use the file system
and let's read the file names
from the raw data directory
like this
then I'm going to create an array for
the samples where we're going to store
information about each sample
and I will initialize an ID with one I
want to give IDs to each individual
sample
now for each file name let's call it FN
for short
I'm going to extract the content
from the raw directory
concatenating with
the name of the file like so so this
contains a string of characters one for
each of the files in that raw directory
from this string I'll extract the
session information the student
information and the drawings
by first parsing the string into Json
and then using the destructuring
assignment here
now we'll have a sample for each drawing
so I'm going to write here for label in
drawings the label is going to be what
the drawing was of I will push to the
samples array
a new object
with the ID
the label
and now I'm going to call student name
what we previously had student
and because student names are not
necessarily unique I'm going to also add
here student ID
session like this the sessions were made
to be unique
now let's increment this ID
and move on to write this samples array
into our samples file I go down here
like this and write
file sync in the
samples a Json stringified version of
this array
now to test this code we are going to go
to the terminal and write
node
data set generator
dot Js
and something happened if we look here
in the data and the data set
there is a new file created called
samples Json and it looks like this if
you want this to look nicer you can
install a visual studio code extension
for Json
then you can press something like Ctrl
shift J
and it will format it like this but you
can see now some of my drawings are here
and there's an entry here for the car an
entry for the fish an entry for the
house tree and so on then other users
follow as well
now this is just a summary here to
generate the data associated with each
sample I'm going to go here
before moving on to the next item
and I'll write
write file sync
into the Json directory
and the file will be named after the ID
dot Json simple enough we just have to
stringify here
the drawing of that specific label let's
save this and rerun our script here in
the terminal you can simply press the up
arrow and it will retype the last
command
it took a little longer this time but if
we look inside of this Json directory
you can see an entry for each sample and
if you click on it you'll see all the
data needed to make that drawing it's
the array containing all the paths and
each path contains points
now for each of these entries I also
want to have an image representation
they will go in this image directory
where we draw these paths essentially
this these are the paths
let's rename these to parts and I'm
going to extract here
paths
is the drawings
of label
so let's write the new code for doing
that
we'll make a function called generate
image file and this will take the output
file
path in the image directory
it will be called the same but the
extension will be PNG and here we add
the paths as well
now we'll implement this generate image
file function here at the bottom
it will have two parameters the output
file
and the paths
and to draw them we'll use a canvas and
we'll use the draw
paths function from our web application
from last time
this one right here
so we're gonna go and write draw paths
on the context
the paths and we want to store these
drawings as an image so we can write
here buffer
canvas to buffer
a PNG image
which we write
in the output file
like so now this won't work yet because
this draw paths function needs to be
referenced first and we need to move it
from here to a common place that both
the web and our node scripts can access
so let's close these to avoid confusion
and here I'm going to create a new
directory called
common
and in it I'm going to move this draw JS
file from here now inside this file for
it to work in node.js we need to export
this
and we do that by typing module
exports
is equal to draw we want to export the
entire object and in our data set
generator all the way at the top we have
to include this file by typing
draw is equal to require
dot dot slash common slash draw Js the
dot dot here just means we go up a
folder
so now the draw exists but we still need
the canvas and unlike in the browser
here we have to install the canvas
separately
we go to the terminal and type
npm
install
canvas
and now the node package manager is
installing the canvas on our system
now I basically installed the library
even though I set no libraries in the
course intro
to make things worse we also used and
will continue to use the math Library so
I kind of lied but the browser has the
canvas there by default and I think that
we all take math and drawing functions
for granted nowadays and if you don't
sorry but I definitely won't teach you
how to draw lines or how mathematical
functions are implemented not in this
course at least
you can see here in the node directory
some new files appeared and even a new
folder
this package Json just says that the
canvas was installed this gives more
details and this is where the binaries
are
now back in our data set generator at
the top we can require the create canvas
function
from the canvas module
and use it to create a canvas
of 400 by 400 the same size we had in
our drawing app
we can also get the reference to the
drawing context
same as in the web
version and here at the bottom we are
using it to draw the paths on the canvas
and then storing it as an image but it's
the same canvas for each of the samples
so I'm going to have to clear it
before drawing the New Paths
now let me open this to show you what
happens next I'm gonna go in data data
set image and in the terminal let's type
node data set
generator
dot JS again
you can see it takes a while this time
and here our image files are being
generated
and the number is growing and growing
and growing it takes longer than
generating just the Json files and if I
click this up here you can actually see
how they look like
okay the script is done but now there's
a problem because we broke our drawing
app from last time down here where we
have our draw JS included we need to
include it now from
dot dot slash common
save the file and let's write a test
you can see here it says module is not
defined and that's because in draw JS
the browser doesn't know what module is
we can fix this by typing if type of
module is not undefined
then we are going to do this which will
make the node code work
now I refresh
and everything still works as before
we'll be using this kind of structure
throughout the course
let's apply the same on the constants
right here we're going to separate them
in another file
I will require the file here it will be
constants JS and we will take out the
constants here like so and now I'm going
to cut all this code from here
it's in my clipboard
save this file and in common
I will add a new file called constants
JS I paste everything from earlier and
at the bottom we need to type
if the type of module is not undefined
we export the constants now if we go
back to the terminal and rerun the
script
it works but it's slow and it would be
nice to have a progress indicator here
I'll Implement one in a new file called
utils
let's write here utils Js
and we create the utils object
and in it let's add the function called
print progress with two parameters it
will have a count and the max value when
the count reaches Max it's a hundred
percent now we'll use process
STD out to get the standard output we
clear the line
and we move the cursor in the standard
output back to zero this will
essentially delete the line in the
console
now we can calculate the percent I'm
going to implement the function for
formatting a percent in just a second so
that will be format percent
of the count divided by Max I just want
it to look like a percent value you'll
see and then we'll write
to the standard output like so first how
many
from the max are there and then I'm
going to concatenate
with this percent
in parenthesis like this above here I'm
going to implement this
format percent function which just takes
a value and it's going to return the
value multiplied by 100 and then I want
to have a two decimal Precision here I
will also concatenate the percent symbol
now let's export this object down here
if type of module is not undefined
we add it to the exports
save the file and let's include it next
in our dataset generation here at the
top
let's copy this
utils
utils and here I'm going to write
print progress
according to this ID so the ID is going
to be the count and then the maximum
value is actually the
number of files in that directory
multiplied by 8 because each file
contains eight drawings let's save this
rerun the script and now we have a nice
progress indicator here
now keep in mind that these images are
already here and what this script is
doing is regenerating them over and over
again every time we run it
I just did this to teach you about the
file structure and the progress
indicator
okay it's done now we're going to start
building a web application that can
display this data set
but before that we need to store it in a
way that the browser can read it as well
I'm gonna go here in common and create a
folder
called JS underscore objects
this folder is going to contain files we
use to communicate between our node
scripts and the web apps we're gonna
make
I'm gonna go to constance.js
and add here
a path to this JS objects directory
like this and here we're going to create
the samples JavaScript file similar to
the samples Json but it will initialize
a JavaScript object in it as well
you'll see
inside of JS objects and it will be
called
samples.js this time we write this file
in dataset generator at the bottom by
copying this
adding here samples underscore Js and
instead of just stringifying here I'm
going to add const samples
is equal to and I will concatenate with
this string
and add here
a semicolon at the end now let's rerun
this script
we can see the file now here
it's essentially the same as samples but
with this beginning part right here and
a semicolon at the end
now this kind of structure I'm using
here is not really standard and I won't
go into much detail as to why I chose it
for this course
but in short it's to avoid course I
thought the web server is too much
trouble and the vs code live server
extension is buggy with some of the
things we'll do later at least on my
computer
but feel free to reorganize this if you
have better ideas
we are going to create a viewer app for
our data set here in the web part let's
create a new file
viewer dot HTML and begin to write some
basic HTML
in the head I will include this meta
tag for supporting UTF characters and
the title will be data viewer
we'll also link
the external style sheet from the same
directory
styles.css let's close the head
and in the body I'm going to start by
writing the title in an H1 tag data
viewer
and let's have here a div
with an ID of container this will
contain the data set
let's close this div and include our
samples JavaScript file we just created
we're gonna need few other JavaScript
files from common I'm just going to copy
this two times and here I'm going to
include
constants
Js
and here utils
now here I'm going to open a script tag
and let's just log those samples to see
if we have them in the browser
close the body and the HTML tag
I'm going to save this and open this
viewer HTML and there they are in the
console
our samples all
3968 of them we can investigate them
here
what they are
who made them and so on next I want to
create a table with these samples so
that each row are all the samples from
one specific user I'm going to have to
group these by the student ID let's go
to this utilsjs and Implement a group by
function there
here at the bottom let's type utils
group by
a given array and the given key it's
going to be a general function that can
Group by any key in our case we'll use
student ID
let's initialize the groups as an empty
object
and for each object of object array
I'm going to get the value of that key
if these groups of that value
is no in our case this means if the
student ID was just identified we don't
have any drawings from them yet
we initialize it with an empty array
and then we push
to that student ID
the whole object and return these groups
now in viewer HTML let's remove this log
and first
get the groups
by grouping by
the student ID
and let's log these ones now to see how
it works
save the file
refresh
and you can see the output is a little
bit different this time
if we open it up I can see for each
student ID
I have eight different samples
the car Fish House 3 bicycle
so these are per user
Miguel Fernandez in this case
let's create the table next
so I'm going to Loop
given each student ID like this
I'm going to refer to the samples as the
groups of this student ID and let's take
out the student name as well for clarity
I just take it from the first sample
student name like so and let's create a
function called create row that on a
given container in this case our div
from above
it will display
a row with the name the student name on
the left
and then the samples one after the other
towards the right
let's close this for Loop and we'll use
this create row function in other
applications as well so I'm going to
write it in a different file
it's going to be a file called display
Js
in our JavaScript directory here
so let's create it
display
Js
and the create row function goes in here
like this with the three parameters
and first we create a row
which is going to be a simple div
we create
the div
and let's add the styles for these as
well we'll have to modify the CSS
afterwards
I'm going to add a class for this row
let's call it row
and append to the container
this div like so I will continue now
with the label
which is also going to be a div
and I'm going to set the HTML of this
div to be the student name
the second parameter
now also a class for the label let's
call this row label
which we can control in CSS
and append to the row
the row label so our div from previously
now has the label to begin with
and Below we're gonna Loop through the
samples and add each of them
independently
sample of samples
I will take out here just the ID and the
label of the samples they are really all
that we need
and I'm going to create an image element
next
like so and I will assign the source of
this image to be the path of this image
file I'll take that from our constants
image directory and concatenate with
the ID
dot PNG
that's where the file is
I'm also going to add a style for this
image
let's call this thumb it will be a
thumbnail size
and append each of these images
to our row
let's close this create row function
save the file and if we refresh the page
we can see something here it's Radu and
then some drawings here
and then another Rado I actually Drew
twice
then Yasin and so on but these don't
look good without the CSS
I'm gonna go at the bottom here and add
row
using display Flex
and the thumbnail will have a width of
10 percent
and the row label will have a little bit
wider width so that we can see the name
of the person
let's save this
refresh
wow it looks like the Finnish prime
minister is here
hello
I don't believe it's actually her but
who knows in this day and age everyone
learns coding
okay but we can do better long names
like this don't really fit in and also
the names here don't really align with
the center of the samples here I'm gonna
fix that by writing here align items to
Center
and for the row label I'm gonna add
ellipses
so text overflow set to ellipses I'm
gonna hide the Overflow and no wrap for
the white space
let's save this refresh
sorry Gustavo but it's okay when we
watch this on the larger screen all the
text will appear there now I want these
drawings to have a white background each
so I'm going to go to display Js
here and wrap them inside of a div a
sample container
create a div
and I'm going to add an ID to this div
we'll need it later it's going to be
sample underscore and the ID of the
sample it's going to uniquely identify
it
I'll also add class to this let's call
sample container
and I'm also going to add the label the
true label of this object what it is
so it's going to be another div
where we set the inner HTML
to the label
and we append
the label to this sample
container first
then here after we have the image I'm
also going to append
it to the sample container
and below here where we append to the
row we don't append the image anymore we
append the sample container
okay save the file refresh the page
and it's worse than before but that's
okay we'll fix it in CSS
I'm gonna implement the
class for the sample container first
we'll give it the white background
text aligned Center
order radius 10 percent I wanted to have
round corners
and margin 1 pixel now I'll explain this
Flex part a little bit later
let me also modify now this thumbnail
here to be 100 this time
and the row label will have this
property here
let's save this
refresh
and what happens now is that
horizontally each of these eight
different
samples
are taking 10 percent of the space and
20 percent of the space is taken by this
label on the left that's what this two
here is for and the other ones are just
one so that's why this one here is four
you can see that this bicycle doesn't
fit very well here and if I'm gonna zoom
in
others have issues as well it's because
they try to fit in the text here I'm
using a very small screen here we're
testing so this is not really a big deal
this will be a desktop application not
the mobile app but we can do a quick fix
here by typing an overflow of hidden
to the sample container save the file
refresh the page
and now the structure is good but the
text doesn't fit entirely but it's not a
big deal on a normal zoom level and a
larger screen it's just fine
now before we look a bit through these
drawings I have to talk a bit about
flagged users you see some people made
some drawings that I think might get me
in trouble
I'm gonna go to utilsjs
and
add here who they are
flagged users
and I'm going to paste here an array I
created earlier
that looks like this
these are their IDs now in display.js
I'm going to destructure here to take
out the student ID as well and then here
where we have that image I'm going to
write
if the flagged users
includes this student ID
I will add the class
to blur it
in CSS we'll Define this blur class
where we just apply the blur filter with
5 pixels like this
let's save this refresh the page
and now we can have a look at the data
let's make it bigger
okay my two drawings are here that I did
in the beginning
and then wow
this might be bo from free code camp
he also commented on YouTube using
emojis I got an idea from that
you'll see
another me
awesome
wow
this one is really nice
oh my
this house is amazing
some text here this is going to be tough
wow some of these drawings are
how long did you spend on this
this is funny I think some of you
thought that it says horse instead of
house I've noticed some of these
problems
no big deal it makes the data more
challenging
wow this is a really nice car
giving me Mafia vibes
okay this is something
we'll have to talk about the data
cleaning at some point and how it
improves the models
wow
these are amazing
foreign
look at that
You Know Who You Are
wow very different looking tree here
wow
and the Christmas tree oh this is
fitting
it's soon Christmas when I'm filming
this
and a couple of more horses here where
the house should be
I'm quite sure these are honest mistakes
look at this
wow
basic coder but not so basic drawings
I don't know why I'm thinking about
Magikarp now
ah jeans
ah
as you can see some of these drawings
are really detailed and must have taken
a really long time to draw that makes
our data slightly different than the one
from Quick Draw they have a time limit
we also have an undo button to fix
mistakes so our drawings should be
better on average
think you can organize or style the page
in a better way
share your version with me and I'll
showcase my favorites in a future video
we're gonna Implement functions to
extract features from these samples
in a file in common
we're gonna call this file features dot
Js
and we'll add these functions to an
object called features
like so
first function will be to get the path
count
from the given paths it's a really
simple one we just return here
how many paths there are by outputting
the length of the array
and another simple function will be to
get the point count
from the given paths
to do this we're going to flatten the
array of paths first
this just converts the array of array of
points into one big array of points with
all of them and then we return
points.length as before
we need to export this since we're
working with node
but because we're going to use this in
the web applications as well I'm going
to check if module exists before that
let's save this file and move to the
node directory where we're going to
create our feature extraction script
let's create a new file here called
feature extractor
dot Js
and begin by including the constants
from common constants JS and I'm going
to include also the features
file that we just created
now I'm going to use the file system
and begin by reading the samples
I'll do this in one line here by parsing
whatever is inside
the samples
file and then to extract the features we
are going to Loop
through all of the samples
and from each sample we will get the
paths by parsing
whatever is inside
the Json file
containing the paths
identified by the sample ID
dot Json
I'm going to create the data point now
consisting of two feature values the
path count and the point count but
because we can have many features I'm
going to use an array here then we don't
need to worry about x y z and so on so
I'm going to type sample dot point I'm
going to add this information to the
sample and say an array with get path
count from the paths
and get Point count
from the paths like so let me close this
for Loop and before we can write this to
a features file I'm going to also
mention here what are the names we want
these features to have path count Point
count
and now I'm going to write
all this information
in a new file
we have to implement this constant soon
and I'm going to stringify
a new object with the feature names and
the samples I just combined both of them
in one file
let's save this and Define this constant
next so I'm going to constants
and under these samples here I'm going
to write
features
also in the data set directory another
file called features.json
let's save this file go to our terminal
and type node
feature extractor.js
and this one ends quite quickly I won't
need a progress indicator for it but I
will go up here and write the log
saying extracting features so I know
it's happening
and at the bottom I will just output
done
now let's have a look in our data data
set
features to see how they look like we
can see the feature names as the first
attribute and the samples which is
pretty much the same as samples Json but
also the point value here as well
now strictly speaking a feature file
wouldn't contain things like this they
are kind of extra maybe this ID as well
and that's okay we can exclude them if
we really need it we can type here
samples remap them given a sample s we
will remap it to B
an object containing just a point
and just a label
like this
if I rerun the script
we have just this now
but for convenience I'm also going to
keep the previous version with all the
data combined it will help when building
the web applications I'm going to go to
constants and here at the end I will
Define a new file path for another
Javascript file which will hold this
information
again
as a JavaScript object in a JavaScript
file let's save this and in our feature
extractor at the end
I'm going to write
in this new file features
underscore Js
I'll start the template literal so I'm
using a backtick in this way I can write
on multiple lines
and I can also include
the value
coming from the feature names
and the samples as Json so here I'm
including everything not just the point
and the label
let me close this and the backtick
and this function call
I'll save the file re-run the script
and now in JavaScript objects here we
can see features.js as well which is the
same thing from previously but assigned
to a features object
we'll update the web application first
for viewing the data our web viewer and
the first thing we do here is say that
we want to use this features JS file
instead of the samples.js and since it
has everything as the samples.js and
more we can take out the samples from
there and our code here will still work
we can also take out the feature names
now
from the features Global value and
features.js
I'm going to save this
and if we refresh this the code still
works but now if I'm going to open the
console here and type
feature names they are here and if I'm
going to look at the samples
they contain some additional information
like the feature values here in the
point these points are what we're going
to visualize next using a Google chart
and yeah I know I said no libraries
but this is a temporary thing you'll see
we'll display the chart
in a new div called chart container
and Google charts expect first here some
options I'm going to start to Define
these options in an object
the width for example 400 pixels
the height
now the horizontal axis title will be
coming from feature names of zero and
the vertical axis title comes from
feature names of One
I'm gonna remove the legend because I
think it takes too much space and my
screen size here is limited and I will
load
the most recent version
of the core chart package
like this now this load expects a
callback it's not going to happen
instantly and we can write that here
like so and we can generate the data in
a form that Google likes so let's put
here
a new
data table
with two columns
one for the first feature value
a number
and we'll write here the feature names
of zero and another column will hold
another number for feature names of one
these are not the actual values the
values go here in add rows where we take
all the samples and we remap them to
keep just the point value
this will work
we can create the chart now
using the Google visualization
scatter chart
where we call draw
with the data and the options right here
now if I'm going to save this and
refresh the page it takes a while but
eventually we have it here and wow we
can see now
some drawings have like 200 paths and 15
000 points this is amazing I don't think
mine have something like that I'm really
curious to see which these are from the
data and we'll get to that but first
let's see if we can zoom into this place
I want to investigate even deeper and by
default this won't let me unless I go
here and add few more options
like Explorer
actions drag to zoom if I refresh
I can now zoom in by drawing this kind
of region with the mouse
to zoom out you need to add something
more it will happen on right click and
we can do that here
right click reset
as far as I know it's the only way
possible and once you zoom in you can
now Zoom back to the very beginning
which is a little bit inconvenient
because maybe you want to zoom out only
a little bit but you can't and another
problem is I can't zoom in deep enough
I need to pass something more here
Max zoom in value of 0.01 this will be
enough for our needs and now I can zoom
in
very deep like so we can also use
different colors one for each class
I'm gonna go here and show you how to do
that we are going to add another column
which is going to be used for styling
it's going to be a string with the roll
of styling
but because we have now three columns
here our Point has just two values we
need to do something about it so I'm
going to generate here a new array
and then I go inside it
and first thing I do is spread
the point value of the sample into two
different values and then the third
value will be a style that we will need
to Define I'll Define these in utils
and one for each label
let's save this
go to utils JS in common
and implement the Styles here at the top
let's say the car should be Gray
the fish red
house yellow
the tree green
bicycle cyan
guitar blue
pencil magenta
and the clock light gray
these are all primary sh colors and then
dark gray light gray this should be okay
let's save this
refresh
and now you see these different colors
right here
wow
but one thing I really wanted to have
here is transparency it gives an idea of
the density in different parts
unfortunately this wasn't as easy as I
thought you can't just put here colors
with Alpha values it it won't work but
what did work is to use a slightly
different version of the Google chart
the different Library which they called
the materials charts which supports
transparency as well
to do that you have to replace here core
chart with scatter in our case or you
can add that one as well if you want to
support both and this bottom part right
here will be a little bit different let
me just comment it out for reference so
you can see what changes and here you
type
chart
Google charts
scattered this time so it's a little bit
different
and here we draw the data
and now we need to convert these options
in a new format luckily Google has an
option for this
convert options
from options to these new new form that
the new version of the charts expects
now we save this refresh
and it looks a little bit different and
transparency is here but unfortunately a
lot of things are not I can't zoom in
anymore I don't have the colors there
and there is no support for this so I
can either choose one chart variant or
another one and
I preferred the previous one actually
to get the best of both worlds and more
we'll use a different chart here one
I've implemented if you want to see how
it's made check out the video on my
channel otherwise you can skip that part
we will edit the code a bit later but
they are minor changes and you can
handle it I think now get the chart code
from the link in the description and
let's add it to the project
I'm going to go here in the web and
create a new folder
chart
and here I'm going to add the chart code
we'll only need the JavaScript files
here so I'm going to remove these other
ones
so they are these files right here
now we can remove the Google chart from
here
and replace it with our own script from
chart
.js
and we'll need to add the other two ones
as well
the one for the chart graphics
and the one for the math
now here the options I tried to simplify
a little bit all my charts are usually
Square in aspect ratio so I just put
here size and the other ones I replaced
with axes labels
just the feature names directly and then
the Styles I pass those from utils like
so
and this part we can remove
and Define our chart using
chart
is equal to new chart
on the chart container
showing the samples with these options
like so I'm going to save this
refresh the page and this is our version
we can zoom in
we can drag
the transparency is not exactly what I
wanted so I'm going to pass here to the
options this transparency and let's set
it to a low value it looks like there
are a lot of points here overlapping and
I need a low transparency to be able to
see them refresh and the data is really
really dense here you can clearly see
that now
but we can do more stylistic changes I'm
gonna go to utils and change these
colors into an object
I'm going to add here for each of them
a caller attribute and that's because
here we can also add
a text field
where I'm going to add emojis one by one
now before we try this text let's see
how the colors look
and I think because the contrast is not
so strong with the colors
I want to set the transparency to 0.7
yeah
and to get the text appearing there the
Emojis we can type here
icon
text
so now we get these emojis here instead
of the colors which are quite good
because it means that we can see what
these points represent without having a
need for labels on the side labels make
your eyes go always to the side to see
what something is and colors on their
own are problematic to many people who
have trouble distinguishing them I think
this is a good idea but we could combine
the colors with these shapes to make
something more interesting so that's why
there is support here also for the image
where we generate the images
for these different objects according to
this text right here and the specified
color
I will generate these images by typing
Graphics generate images
for these Styles defined in utils
now I refresh
and you may see nothing here at first
but if you're gonna drag your mouse over
this they will appear and now the colors
of these different shapes are depending
on the colors specified
in utils right here
now our chart supports another parameter
here a callback function for what to do
when selecting an item we'll use this to
identify it in the table below
let's call this function handle click
and we'll implement it in display Js
at the bottom here
the handle click function given a sample
it's going to get the element by ID
of sample and the sample ID with an
underscore in between so this is how we
defined these IDs to be up here
and then
it's going to add a class to this item
called emphasize let's save this file
and in style CSS I'm going to implement
this
emphasize class where I just set the
background color
to Yellow
let's save everything refresh
and now when we click on something like
this car
the item should be also emphasized
somewhere
in this very long list
it took a while but here it is so this
is the car with the most number of
points Claudius car
ah I see it's because of all this
shading Claudia really took drawing
seriously here
but let's make it next so we don't have
to scroll through this list it's going
to work automatically
we go back to display Js
and after we emphasize we write here
scroll into view for that element
with an auto Behavior you can also try
smooth but I like things to happen fast
and block Center will make it scroll to
be in the middle of the page let's close
this
save the file refresh and now if we
press the car we immediately jump to
Claudius car
and if I'm gonna go back up let's check
this house
this is amazing Claudio has both items
with the most number of points
and we also see a problem here we
shouldn't have two emphasized items
anymore let's fix this I'm going to take
all the
emphasized items in an array
like this
and then for each item in this array for
each element e we are going to remove
the emphasized glass
let's save
refresh now I click the car
now I go up
and I click the house
works but I don't want to go up all the
time I need to select something new
let's have the chart on the side and the
other content on the left and the chart
will not move on scroll I'll first go to
style CSS and make our container
to have a width calculated from the
hundred percent minus the width of the
chart of 400 percent like this make sure
you have these spaces here they're
important I'm going to save this refresh
and if I'm gonna zoom out a bit
you can see the space here this is where
the chart is going to be
back to CSS
we can Define here the style for chart
container Position will be fixed
right will be zero
top will be 50 and this will just make
its top part to be in the middle I want
it to be in the middle so
we Translate
nothing horizontally but by minus 50
percent of its height vertically
let's save this
refresh and now if I'm going to press
these items
I don't need to scroll back to the Chart
anymore
I would also like to have selection
happen the other way around like
clicking on these items
to do that we go to display Js
at the top here and add our click
Handler also to the sample container
like so
and if we refresh
and click this fish
it selects it but it also moves it here
in the middle of the screen and I don't
want this behavior when I'm clicking in
the table itself I do want it for the
chart but not here so let's specify here
a parameter set to false
it's gonna be do scroll
True by default but only if true
is going to do this scroll into view
section here
let's save
refresh and now clicking on these things
emphasizes them as well but not yet on
the chart for that we need to go back
here and say
chart select sample
sample
we can save this
refresh and now we can see where this
fish is in the feature space
this is a nice fish by the way
wow and James drew a Christmas tree
I didn't think about doing something
like that
now there's actually one problem here
that causes an error if I'm gonna click
here in the empty space
to select nothing this handle click now
breaks because sample is null so we need
to take care of this here at the top I'm
going to do a quick check if sample is
null
then let's just de-emphasize everything
just in case and I'm going to return
this breaks because we are trying to
access its ID here we can also deselect
the sample by clicking on it again
so we can check here if the element
is already emphasized the one that we
clicked on no matter in the chart or in
the list
we are going to remove
the emphasize class from it
we're also going to tell the chart to
select nothing if we clicked on this
from the list on the left and then we
return we don't want to disturb the
functionality when we're actually
selecting something here which still
needs this de-emphasize code from
previously
like so
let's save this
refresh and now if we click here no
error if I'm gonna click on the house
it's going to select it if I'm going to
click outside here it will deselect it
both from here and from the list if I'll
click this bicycle
it will select it both here and there if
I'm gonna click on it again
it will deselect it
and the same deselection happens if we
click on it again here on the chart
so this is now the full chart
functionality done
Let's test bigger
I think we can have a little bit larger
chart here
so in viewer HTML I'm going to set this
to maybe 500 save style CSS we also have
to subtract here 500. and save let's
refresh
yeah I like this
let's see what this tree is here it has
so many paths
ah okay Daniel here drew it so that
it has many many many branches
200 something branches wow
actually I think there's detail also
here
really nice
let's see what else is here
wow okay
nikoni has these drawings here with a
lot of content this will be tough
wow such a nice car here
so much detail
aiman must have spent a lot of time on
this
herminho's bicycle also has many points
same kind of style here with the shading
actually nikoni seems to use it too
having a fast responsive system like
this is a huge help when you inspect
your data otherwise you'd have to do a
lot of manual work like maybe get the ID
somehow and look for it in the files
it's slow and mistakes can happen try
working smart all the time and avoid
silly mistakes like that
can you extract two other features from
the samples and show them on the chart
if you need inspiration you can watch my
older video here it also teaches how to
extract features from the pixels
something we'll do a bit later
now when you're done look at the
structure is it any better useful
features should group together samples
of the same type
share your code and screenshots with me
and I'll include the best ones in a
future video
let's organize these Imports here in
viewer HTML
we have at the top this features object
containing information about the samples
and their features
now here we have the common code with
the node.js script
the display part right here
and these ones below are for the chart
let's add the new script where we
include the sketch pad
for the sketch pad to work we also need
to include
the draw Js
file from common and we'll use the
sketchpad as an input to draw something
to be classified
I'm gonna go up here and prepare a
container for it let's say input
container
like so and at the very bottom I'm going
to initialize
a sketch pad
on the input container and save the file
let's refresh
and there is our sketch pad right here
and it works this is the benefit of
working with components
now let's add some styles for it I want
it to float as well over the data next
to the chart
in style CSS I'm gonna go at the bottom
and Define here a style for input
container
position fixed
I'm gonna give it 500 pixels from the
right that's how large the chart is
and 50 from the top and we translate
again
not on the horizontal axis but by minus
50 vertically so it's centered on the
screen
to get that undo button in the middle
I'll set the text align to Center
and let's give it also a margin of 10
pixels so it doesn't exactly touch the
chart
let's save this refresh
and now it's here and when we scroll it
stays in place but it's blocking our
data I want to be able to hide it as
well
so in viewer HTML we'll need to add the
control panel
it's going to be a div right here
and the button inside it on click will
toggle the input visible or not
let's give it a name
and this toggle input function I'm going
to implement in display Js
at the bottom right here we will write
toggle input
if the input container
display
is none
then we need to set it to be visible
I'll set it to block
otherwise
I will set it to none
let's save this refresh
and the button is here
and it works but let's put it up here
over the chart there's a lot of empty
space there
in style CSS I'll add a style for our
control panel
position it to fixed
right zero top zero
I'm gonna give it the same width as the
chart just so it aligns well and then
text the Line to Center so it's going to
be in the middle of that 500 pixel area
and let's have it
with the padding of
10 pixels
refresh
and it's right here
now I want when this input is here to
somehow hide what's in the background
and I found a funny way to do this in
viewer HTML
below the sketch pad right here I'm
going to give the canvas
of the sketch pad Style
using CSS text I'm gonna append to its
existing style it already has some
things there
an outline
10 pixels
solid red for now
and it looks like this
but I'm gonna make it really big
so really really big like
this big and refresh
you can see it's hiding everything there
and if we change the color to a
transparent
black
it's gonna look like this and I think
it's pretty nice
it's only like that when it's on
now when we draw something here I want
to immediately show the features on the
chart
so we'll need that information here on
update
let's open the sketch pad and add here a
second parameter
on update which can be null
let's store this callback function here
as an attribute
and in our redraw method at the very end
here I'm going to check if this update
callback exists
and call it with all the paths
let's save this and now in viewer HTML
we can pass here
a function on drawing update
which I'm going to implement right here
what to do when the drawing updates
with the paths and what we have to do is
extract the features in the same way we
did in the feature extractor
here and node
feature extractor we have this part
right here where we're doing it
let's paste it here
and let's just Define this as a constant
and log it right here
now if we save the file and refresh the
page
we're going to get an error here
features get path count is not a
function and the problem is that we have
two objects called features this one
here should be the one in common
here
it has the feature functions
but it conflicts with the one from here
in JS objects we also call features
these samples that have also the feature
values
maybe this is not the best naming
convention here but I think we can
actually
rename this one to feature functions
everywhere
so let's do it
feature functions
feature functions feature functions I
will also rename the file to feature
functions as well
and we have to fix it in the feature
extractor
feature functions
rename symbol
save the file and finally in viewer HTML
let's separately include now
feature functions
and replace this
as well save the file
refresh the page
and you can see here 0 0 because the
sketch pad
is redrawing itself on the beginning
and the paths are empty so the path
count is zero and the point count is
also zero
but if I'm going to start to draw
something here
you can see the first number is the path
count and the second number is the point
count how many points are being drawn
if I'm going to start another path
I have two and the point count is still
going up
and so on
it also updates on undo
we're back to zero zero now let's close
some of these files right here there are
too many open right now
and these folders right here
let's show this point on the chart next
and it's going to be a dynamic point
that moves as we are drawing this is not
the standard component charts have but
we can add it to our own since we built
it let's remove this log and say
show Dynamic point
at this point location let's save this
and in chart.js I'm going to go
just below the Constructor
and add here
show Dynamic Point as a public method
given a point
let's set
an attribute
to this value
and redraw
now this Dynamic point is going to be
here on attribute
of the chart
class
initially it's going to be no and to
draw it will go in this draw method
at the end just before drawing the axes
and if we have one of these Dynamic
points we'll first have to get the pixel
location of this data point
so we remap
from the data bounds that's how the
features are represented
to the pixel bounds
and here we can draw this point using
our draw Point function from the
graphics file
it's gonna be black for now
let's save this
refresh
and there should be something at 0 0 but
this chart starts now at 1 and 10
because that's apparently the smallest
value for the path count and the point
count we need to have at least one path
to make it a drawing
so if we drag this we should be able to
see this
dot right here
that should be moving as we are drawing
something so when I'm gonna start to
draw it should immediately jump to this
one location for the path count and then
as the path grows it's going to go up in
this direction let's see
yes
and now if I'm going to stop this path
and create a new one it's going to
teleport to this right column here
and continue going up from there but
it's not very visible here and we can
make it better you see before drawing
the point in Black here I'm going to
draw another point
the same location
and it's going to be a transparent white
point
with the very very very big size let's
put here
10 million I basically want when I
refresh
to see this point on top of this faded
background it's much more visible and
the value needs to be so big because the
chart can be zoomed in and I want that
if you zoom in like this and then you go
to some extreme Corner this region
doesn't run out so let's see now how it
looks like when we are drawing
much clearer what is happening there
now if I'm gonna press toggle input
it's still here and I want it gone
above where we have our show Dynamic
input I'm just gonna copy it and right
here
hide Dynamic input where we're gonna put
Dynamic point to null and we don't need
this parameter here let's save this and
in display JS when the input container
is made invisible we also hide the
dynamic Point save refresh
and now when we press toggle input
the data here becomes clear because that
faded region goes away
but I wanted to come back when I press
the toggle input now it does appear
again when we start drawing
so if we can get this sketch pad to
trigger an update it's gonna work
let's save this and in sketchpad.js
I'm gonna go
here
and implement the trigger update method
where I just put this code from here
like so and since we have now this
method I'm going to right here trigger
update so the logic doesn't change
let's save this
refresh
look at that point creeping in here
very very
small movement
there's a long way to go to 15 000
points
yeah but it works
now before we start to talk about
classification we would need this data
to look like
something to have a structure and these
features are just not very good it looks
really mixed in my opinion so let's try
to compute some other features I'm gonna
go to Common feature functions and let's
calculate the width of the drawing for
that I'm going to write a function
called get with
given the paths
we take out the points as we did in the
get Point count
function and now I'm going to focus just
on the x coordinate by taking the zeroth
value of the point to get the width of
the drawing we'll need the minimum and
the maximum
the minimum can be found using the mean
function of the math Library if we
spread out this x array
and the same thing for the maximum
like so and the width will just be the
maximum minus the minimum like this and
since we have the width we can also get
the height in a similar way they are
really easy to understand features and
usually they work well let me just copy
this and this will be get height
with the Y here
taking out P of 1
and the Y here
and here now we're gonna need to extract
these new features
so we'll have to go to node feature
extractor and change this from the path
count and point count to the width and
height
also these names here need to be changed
in viewer HTML we also need to change
this because we need to change in so
many places we need to find a better way
to restructure this so that we don't get
confused what we use for extracting what
we use for displaying they should just
point to the same resource
so going back in feature functions I'm
going to right here
an object called in use which are the
functions that will be in use and I will
also add their names here how I want
them to be referred to as
so the name width
and the function will be feature
functions
get with
the name height
feature functions
get height
notice we are not calling these
functions here we are just passing them
into this object
now let's save this
and in feature extractor.js we can now
take out those functions
by looking at the feature functions in
use
and only
focusing on the function from there and
to calculate this sample point we can
just do
map
for each of these functions
we call the function on the paths
like this
now we don't need this code from here
they do exactly the same but now with
the new functions we have in use
the code is also more General in the
sense that you can pass any number of
features making this a multi-dimensional
point but I'll teach you about those
later now let's save this file and
regenerate the features in my terminal
in the node directory I will type node
feature
extractor it will work also without the
Js
and now in our data data set features we
should see new values for the width and
height and I think they're proper sensor
canvas is 400 pixels
oh but the feature names are not good we
have to handle these as well we go to
feature extractor.js
and here for the names we just replace
this
with feature functions in use and we
take out the name from there save the
file
regenerate the features I just press up
and enter here
and now the feature names are also
correct to get them to appear on the
website as well
I'm gonna go to feature extractor.js and
just copy these two lines of code
in viewer.js right here
this will be just point
and we can remove this code we don't
need to worry about the feature names
because we just read them from this file
right here
now let's save this
refresh
and there they are now our node scripts
and the web page are in sync
and something is weird here isn't it
look at this one drawing this one house
it has a width of 900 something how can
that be our canvas for drawing on the
sketch pad was 400 maximum what is this
place
let's hide this input and
aha interesting her Nino
looks like this horizontal line somehow
might extend out of the canvas it's
possible that on some devices maybe if
you make a quick line like that it still
records the point I don't know but
interesting and common I have to say in
general when you collect data you have
to expect outliers like this and I think
there are more problems look this height
also goes beyond the 400 which I
expected to be here
let's have a look at this
highest tree here
okay maybe let's not look at that tree
one next to it okay
so this is also above 400.
of course when I'm drawing them here I'm
drawing them on a 400 by 400 canvas but
it looks like it might continue
downwards like this it's strange maybe
some of you can help me figure out
what's going on
there seems to be a clear border here
and I'm quite sure that this is the 400
Mark because I guess on most devices the
app should work yeah it's exactly on the
400 Mark here
and the height maximum height also I
believe it's
here
yeah
but it's actually very common for data
to have problems in fact I'd be
surprised if there were none I've seen
things like this all the time like when
working with location-based data the
most common issue there was to have
coordinates switched but only in parts
of the data another thing was that
people use positive values in the
southern hemisphere maybe that's where
they live and they have a different
convention
anyway we have a few problematic samples
and it's great we'll get to see how they
affect
look at all these pencils
they're here because many people just
draw pencils like a vertical line kind
of thing
which is nice and I'm quite sure that
these here must be pencils drawn
horizontally
like that
but there's even more structure here
look at all these clocks in a line here
and I'm quite sure this happens because
many people draw clocks to have a square
aspect ratio where the width is equal to
the height
guitars are also here
probably because people draw them kind
of like the pencil a vertical line but a
little bit wide because of this part so
they are similar to the pencil in a
sense from their aspect ratio but a
little bit wider
a lot of trees appearing here as well
nice we can definitely work with this
let's see if our input still works
for some reason that transparent overlay
doesn't appear here
it appears when we're drawing but not
before let's debug real quick I'm going
to log here
our Point save the file
refresh the page uh it's minus infinity
minus infinity because you can't
calculate the width and height of
nothing
it's fine it can be like this not a
problem
now the most basic way of doing
classification to figure out what this
drawing is
is to extract its features and then have
a look in the feature space what's
nearby
in this case it's surrounded with trees
so maybe we just classify it as the same
thing that is nearby it that we learned
from the data
so we need to find the nearest sample
relative to this point
and we already have a function for that
when we built the chart in math.js
we have here the get nearest used to
emphasize and select things on the chart
and it also uses this distance function
which is just the length of the
hypotenuse in a triangle using the
Pythagorean theorem
so these are the two things that we need
and instead of making this code modular
in a way that the chart and what we do
next will use the same I'm gonna have a
copy of it this time it's because I want
the chart to be its own component and
have these functions here
so let's copy these
in our utils
at the end right here
this math
is going to be utils
and we have to use it here as well
and here as well
otherwise I think it's the same let's
have a quick look and remember how these
work the get nearest function given a
location and the set of points Begins by
initializing a minimum distance with the
maximum possible number
and then it will return an index the
index of this point not the point itself
we then Loop through all of the points
take out the point like this and
calculate the distance from our given
location to this point store it in D if
this is less than the minimum distance
we update this minimum distance because
we found a better one and we keep a note
of the index finally we return the index
quite easy just the minimum search
pretty much
let's save this go back to our viewer
and here we can remove this logging and
instead of that attempt to classify this
to get the label
from the point
what is this drawing
and let's log this label
our classify function I'm going to write
it below right here for now
and first we need to take out just the
points from our samples so I'm going to
use map
from each sample the point now let's get
the nearest index
using our
get nearest function from utils
like this and we can get the nearest
sample
from the samples at this index like so
and we return the label
from the sample
let's save refresh
and it already says car here for some
reason let's try to draw something maybe
a pencil because that's probably going
to work
yeah I'm really great at drawing a
pencil but it seems to work it says it's
a pencil because our point is here next
to these other pencils and probably one
of these is the closest I think this one
we'll improve this chart to show the
nearest neighbor soon but first let's
display this summer on screen I'm gonna
make a place for it here
inside the input container actually I'm
going to type an ID
predicted label container
let's close this ID
I'm gonna give it a quick style in CSS
I want it to be
White
and relatively large
relatively positioned let's save this
and go back to viewer HTML at the bottom
here
instead of logging it in the console we
are going to
tell our predicted label container to
set its inner HTML
to a text
it will be like
is it uh
concatenating with the label
question mark
make it a bit more funny
refresh
is it a car it says car when nothing is
drawn
but if we draw something
it says now a house this is not really a
house I wanted to draw a clock
but okay now it's a clock
let's undo
back to the house here you can see it's
quite sensitive these features are
definitely not enough to make it
reliable I mean I can do here anything I
want and it's not going to change the
classification or the aspect ratio this
object can be anything depending on what
I draw inside
it just won't have a chance to classify
it using these
two features but it's a start and it
kind of works try it out
a fish seems to work
because there's another fish next to
this one
let's update the chart so it looks nicer
next
I'm going to pass here to show Dynamic
point also the label and in chart JS
here
and this Dynamic point will have both
pieces of information now
it will have the point and the label so
in this draw method we have to take out
here
the point and the label
separately from this Dynamic point
and I'm going to
replace here
with Point like this and instead of a
black dot here I'm going to draw it
using an image using the predicted label
so we take the
Style
from the label the image from that and
place it at the pixel location with the
draw image function from our Graphics
toolkit let's save this
refresh
and now you can see the point changes
its appearance depending on what we are
drawing here
apparently a fish
let's make a line connecting to the
nearest sample here
we could figure out what the nearest
sample is here again but we already have
it here so I'm going to return here the
label
and then also the nearest sample
a little bit redundant but it's okay
and we need to make sure that here where
we call classify we take out both the
label
and the nearest sample
like this and here in show Dynamic point
we can pass the nearest sample
as well
in chart JS we can go up in the
Constructor
and specify a field for this one the
nearest sample set no
and show Dynamic points
is gonna have it here as well where we
can set it to
the nearest sample attribute we just
created
now inside of this draw function
in between these two we can type A New
Path we don't have a function for
drawing a line we just have to move to
with the context to the pixel location
and now we need to go to the nearest
samples point but in the pixel space
so we need to line to remap the point
from the data bounds
to the pixel bounds
using the point from the nearest sample
and let's stroke
this is not really a standard component
and we're probably going to change
things soon anyway so I'm not worried
about the code too much let's save this
refresh
let's draw a card this time
it's uh not a bicycle
and not a fish but let's see why it's a
fish
it's a fish because it's mapped to this
fish right here if it would have just a
little bit more width I think it's going
to go next to this car right here let's
see
let's try to draw very small
yeah it's a car
but it's gonna turn to a house if we
draw a little bit more let's see
okay it's the house
now it's this fish
let's try to get it to that car above
there
increase its height a little bit
okay
now let's get closer to this fish
something's wrong
can you see it let me make it bigger
look at this it claims this fish is the
nearest sample it can't be this car is
definitely closer even this fish
there's nothing wrong with our nearest
neighbor search
our chart is just lying to us
bad chart
it's because it's displaying the data to
fit in this Square aspect ratio here
the width is squished like this
and it gives the illusion that the car
here is closer
but it's not not in the data space and
this is where people start to get
confused they look at things like this
and they don't understand why their
machine learning methods work
differently let's make our charts not
squish or stretch the data and you'll
understand better here where we get the
minimum and maximum X and Y I'm going to
calculate
a Delta an X
as the difference
a Delta on y as the difference and I'm
going to store the maximum of these two
and we'll recompute these maximum values
here for the right will be Min X Plus
Delta and for the top will be mean y
plus Delta
like this
let's save this
refresh
and now our chart looks like this with a
lot of empty space here because the
maximum Delta the one from the width is
applied on the height as well and that's
why most charts don't do this we don't
like empty space in general so
stretching is default functionality here
but it's very confusing if you don't
normalize your data now if I bring my
drawing back here
whoo
and zoom in
we can see that this fish is indeed the
closest now that the squishing doesn't
happen anymore but some kind of
squishing or stretching is usually
applied on the data and to understand
why let's try to visualize the path
count and point count from previously
I'm going to go to feature functions
here let's comment these out
and type here name path count
feature functions get path count
and the second one
Point count
feature functions
get Point count save this in our
terminal
re-extract the features
and look at that all our data is
essentially on one line this path count
feature isn't treated equally at all we
basically have just one dimensional data
here let's zoom in and see this better
and let's try drawing something
this is now our zero zero point it's
classified as a fish according to these
features now and if I'm going to start
drawing
I can see going up
very quickly
increasing the point count
and now a little bit to the right when
the path count increased but to draw
anything you really generate a lot of
points relative to the path count
and if we visualize the data as we did
before I'm gonna keep this other variant
for reference
you will see that this path count has
almost no effect on the classification
let's save
refresh
and let's zoom in here to see what
happens
you can see these columns appearing
again when zooming because of the
squishing now if I draw something I'm
going to jump to this column
and now the point goes up
see how those lines appear claiming that
is the nearest sample instead of this it
is the nearest sample if you look at the
range of this x-axis compared to the
y-axis and as you are drawing
you constantly get those lines to
different columns there because the path
count just doesn't matter
but we want it to matter in general we
want to even the playing round we want
each of these features to have the same
kind of significance and that's why we
need to do data scaling to make these
two features comparable
the width and height we calculated today
are actually those of the bounding box
but some of the drawings are tilted like
this and I think we'd get a better
result if we calculate them some other
way
think you can do it try also visualizing
these rotated bounding boxes in that way
you know your code is good
share screenshots and your code with me
and I'll include my favorite version in
a future video
data scaling is a step we do to give
features the same importance when doing
classification now maybe we don't want
exactly that and we'll talk about adding
weights to Features later but leveling
the playing field is something you need
to know to do anyways and there are two
techniques people commonly use for this
the one I'll focus on is called
normalization where the values are
remapped to be between 0 and 1.
will normalize the data here after we
have the feature values
and we do that by calling a function
we'll need to implement in utils
normalize points that takes the sample
points so from the samples we remap them
to extract just a point like this
now let's save this and go to utils in
common
and implement
at the end of it
the new normalize points function
given the points this function will
change their values to be between 0 and
1.
for that we need to have here the
minimum and maximum on each of the
dimensions each feature corresponds to
one dimension and until now we've been
using just two Dimensions but later I'll
teach you how to use more so let's
prepare this function to be General
enough we'll initialize Min and Max to
be the first point values I'm creating a
new array here with the values so they
don't accidentally get changed later and
same for the max
in the beginning they are just whatever
are the values of the first point but
then we will Loop through the remaining
points starting at one
and now we start to Loop through the
dimensions let's extract these
Dimensions up here
so it's clearer how many there are
they are just going to be equal to
the length of the first point for
example
all of them should be the same now back
down here
we can loop with another variable J
through each of these dimensions
and update Min of J
to be the minimum between the previous
Min of J and whatever the point of I and
J is
same thing for the max but using the
maximum function from the math library
and now we have our Min and Max with
them we transform our data next we
iterate through all the points starting
at zero this time and through all
dimensions
as before
and now our points of I and J will be
modified to be between 0 and 1 by just
subtracting the minimum value and then
dividing by the difference
but this is exactly what the inverse
lerp function is doing
from our chart component I will call it
here
and Implement a new version in utils so
between Min and Max we convert this
given value into a percentage
let's close this
and quickly Implement our inverse slurp
function here
above this one
return
V minus a divided by B minus a
like so save the file and I think we
forgot to include it in feature
extraction so let me go up here
and utils
require utils from common
save the file and in the terminal we
type node
feature
extractor
and if we look in our data data set
features now they are all values between
0 and 1.
and if we refresh the page you can see
this reflected right here 0 and 1 on the
x-axis 0 and 1 on the y-axis
and this is now the true distribution of
the data the chart is not tricking us
anymore
but before we can test the
classification we need to normalize the
features extracted from this drawing
to the same space using the same min max
values computed earlier now my point
just went somewhere very very high up
there it's connected to this car right
here but I can't even fit it on screen
anymore
to do that we need to use these min max
values from here
so let's return them
from this function like this save this
file and in feature extractor we take
them out here
and now at the end I'm going to write
them in one of these JavaScript object
files that we use to communicate with
the interface
we need a new constant for that we'll
call it min max Js
and it will just have min max is equal
to and we stringify
the value of min max
like this save this
and then constants.js
let's add a line for this at the end
constants min max Js
also in the JS objects
min max Js
save this file and let's generate the
file here in JS objects we need to use
the terminal extract the features again
and now the min max values are here in
this file we can now load them in our
viewer HTML
in the same way that we load our
features up here
but with min max instead
and now it's a global variable we'll
need to use them to normalize this point
from here before we attempt to classify
it
so we go here and say utils normalize
points it accepts multiple points but we
can just wrap this one
in an array like that then it will work
but we need to update this normalized
points function to support a given min
max value
right
so back in utils if we pass here also a
min max value in addition to the points
we don't need to calculate them
so we just go here and check if min max
exists that parameter there then Min is
min max dot min max is min max dot Max
and we close this else we have to
recalculate these like so
now let's go to our web page
refresh
and when we draw something here
our point is here right where it needs
to be let's zoom in and see what happens
locally
when we draw the next PATH it will jump
to the right column and then start to go
upwards
but you can see now it's always mapped
as you'd expect we don't get those lines
connecting the columns anymore
good but let's revert to our width and
height features they were much better at
prediction than this
I'll comment these out
so they're here if we need to use them
again
and now we need to re-extract the
features in the terminal
refresh the page and here they are
between 0 and 1 both of them and now if
I input my card drawing from earlier
you can see that it is a car and if we
zoom in here
it's not mapped to that fish anymore
it's mapped to this nearest car because
now the width and height are treated
equally
they're still kind of a strange thing
here though
look how this data looks like because of
this one house from here
what would happen if we remove it
sorry arminio
let's find the ID of this sample I'm
just gonna drag it up here and it's
three one zero seven
I'm going to go to feature extractor and
here after we load the samples I will
say dot filter
the samples
whose ID is not three one zero seven
let's save this and in the terminal
re-extract the features
refresh the page and you can see the
data looks quite different now with just
one sample missing
herminus house from here
now let's bring back my drawing from
earlier
[Music]
and it's a fish
because if we zoom in here
it's now mapped to this fish
the data distribution is different all
because one point was removed
but it was an outlier point
a problematic point so to speak
but I like Terminus house so I'm gonna
bring it back
there it is
normalization is very sensitive to
outlier points one way to deal with this
is to automatically detect outliers and
remove them another way is to use
standardization a different data scaling
technique where instead of Min and Max
we compute the mean and standard
deviation and then remap each feature by
subtracting the mean and dividing by the
standard deviation
standardization is less sensitive to
outliers and it would work better in our
case
think you can implement it share your
code with me and the first to get it
right will get a shout out in a future
video
a generalization of the nearest neighbor
classifier is the K nearest neighbors
classifier where K is the number of
neighbors that will play a role in the
classification
we'll decide the class based on the
majority
let's try drawing something here
oh come on I tried my best
let's see what's around it
there is this one tree here that is
closest
a very tall pointy tree from Montana 57.
but apart from that all these neighbors
are pencils maybe this will work better
if we use more neighbors here and
consider the majority
let's see
in viewer HTML we need to update our
nearest neighbors search here to return
more items
let's go to utils
to the get nearest function and add here
a third parameter k
we set it to 1 by default so by default
we'll return just the nearest neighbor
but otherwise K nearest Neighbors
and let's remove this code we'll write a
more General one instead
I want to return the indices here so
let's take out
objects from our data points so that we
take their value and their index
and return a new object like this so obj
now contains the same thing as points
but as an object where the point is the
value and the other attribute is the
index
next we can sort these
with the following callback function
we return the distance
between our given location and
the value of a minus
the distance between our location
and the value of B this will sort them
so that the nearest ones are first and
then
we can take out just the indices
using the map function like this and
return
the first k
indices now let's save this and in
viewer HTML
here we actually get indices now so
there are many of them and here the
first one is the nearest one let's see
if the code still works now it should be
exactly as before
refresh
and let's Draw Something
if we zoom in
yeah seems to work it finds the nearest
let's change it a little bit increase
its width
yeah all good but now let's find more
neighbors let's say maybe 10.
and handle this New Logic with multiple
values
let's figure out the nearest samples
next
they are going to be coming from the
indices if we map them so that each
index becomes the sample at that index
and we can get the labels of these
samples by typing labels is nearest
samples where we take out the label now
we want to count how many of these are
how many are trees how many are cars and
and so on so I'm gonna prepare an object
for accounts
and for each label of labels
I'm going to update the discounts I will
say counts of label is equal to if
counts of label is defined then I'm
going to increase it
buy one otherwise I'm going to set it to
one it's the first time we found that
item
then we want to figure out the majority
so let's see what is the maximum value
of these counts
I'm going to set max equal to the
maximum
of the values
of counts
I'm getting the values not the keys here
and this is an array so we can spread it
and pass it to our math Max function
and finally we can get the label the
label will be
searched from the labels
as the label where counts of that label
L is Max now we need to fix our code in
several places like here we can just
keep this label as such
and let's return all nearest samples
here so let's put an S here
and also need to make sure up here where
we classify that we get nearest samples
as well we will also be passing nearest
samples
to show Dynamic point we will draw lines
to all of them you'll see we do that
inside of the chart
first we need to update this nearest
sample in the Constructor to nearest
samples
and here
nearest samples
we will use these in our draw method
down here instead of drawing this one
line we are going to
Loop
through all the samples of
this nearest samples
and let's extract the point from here
so this is going to be this part from
here where we convert this point
from the data space to the pixel space
just need to make sure that we're
passing here
sample point and now we can reuse this
point down here
Point like so all of these go inside of
this for Loop
we close the for Loop and save the file
refresh the page
let's Draw Something
and zoom in a bit
and look at all these lines right here
and even though the nearest one is
probably the tree or the fish in this
case it selects the clock because we
have one two three clocks which are more
than everything else
let's change it a bit
wow this is really nice
it looks like it's walking there kind of
like a spider
now I'm having fun watching this instead
of teaching you things
let's see how it looks like on my pencil
from earlier
and it's a pencil
let's see why I'm gonna go up here where
it is in the data space
and it's a pencil because of all these
other pencils around it but is this
really better or does it only work in
this particular case
we'll see
try to calculate the probability for the
classification to be correct based on
the number of neighbors of the predicted
class most libraries have support for
this feature and it's a useful thing to
have
other variants of the nearest neighbor
classifiers exist as well like a version
weighted by distance or one that
considers a fixed size neighborhood
think you can Implement any of these
share your code with me and I'll
showcase my favorite implementations in
a future video
to objectively evaluate the classifier
we'll need to test it on a lot of data
we do this by splitting the data in two
a training set and a testing set
we classify all testing samples
according to their nearest Neighbors in
the training set but we know the correct
labels for these already so we can count
how many classifications are correct and
compute the accuracy to follow along
make sure you have the code from last
time or get my version from GitHub and
let's settle the score between these two
we'll split the data in feature
extractor.js
before we start writing files
I'm going to log here
that we will be generating splits
it's gonna be a fast process it's more
like a comment for us to know what
happens
and here let's decide the training
amount
and I will set that to be
50 of the number of samples
and I will define an empty array for
training and an empty array for testing
we Loop through all the samples
like this
and if we are less than the training
amount we add to the training so the
first half of the samples will be the
training set
and the second half will be the testing
set
now we're going to be writing these into
files as well same as what we did here
with the features both in the Json file
and the JavaScript object
let's paste this here
and rename for training
the samples here need to be the training
array and then
training Js
let's say this object will be called
training
and here I'm going to still refer to
this attribute as samples but set the
value of training and let's copy this
again for testing
I need to be really careful here because
it's very common to make the mistake
where you're testing on the training
data or something like that
so let's rename this to testing and this
here to testing this will be testing Js
this will be testing
and this is testing now we need to
Define all of these constants
so in common constants
I will copy this features
line
and right here
training
training Json
testing
testing Json and this features JS here
at the bottom
I also duplicate it
with training Js
the training JavaScript object
and then testing
Js
testing Javascript file let's save this
and then our terminal we can type node
feature extractor
to get now this new data in our data set
we can find training Json and testing
Json they both have the same format but
the data is different
let's load next these JavaScript objects
for testing and training into our web
application
I'm going up here and we'll copy this
features.js
two times
once for training
and once for testing
and below here we can take out
those samples
like so from the training
and from the testing
the files have also the feature names
but we have those already here now when
we are testing we pretend that we don't
know the label
the labels are here we just forget about
them
so I'm going to Loop through
all of the test samples
and I'm going to store the value of the
label in an attribute called Truth
and replace the label with question mark
I'm storing the truth here because we'll
need it when we calculate the accuracy
you'll see but now let's divide this
code into two where we handle the
training samples and testing samples
separately
I'm gonna group this and copy it below
and right here that these are going to
be the training
groups
coming from grouping the training
samples
let's copy this training groups here
instead of groups and here instead of
groups now the same thing happens below
but with the testing groups
coming from the testing samples
and let's copy here
testing groups testing rules now if we
scroll down in the chart I want to
visualize just the training data the
training samples and in the
classification we need to be very
careful here
we classify using only information from
the training data so training samples
and also here
this one
training samples let's save this and
open the page
you can see the data looks different it
looks like El Nino's house is not part
of the training data it's still here
but we don't know the label for it this
is the case now for all testing samples
in the second half of the page
this is the borderline between the sets
now before continuing we need to talk
about normalization one more time you
see these numbers here they are coming
because we normalize the whole data and
that's not proper we have no idea what
the testing set will be so we should
normalize only with the training data
in feature extractor
we go here where normalizing happens and
we replace this with training
then I'm going to copy this
and normalize
the testing
using here
the min max
from the training
this is proper
but it won't work unless we move this
code below here where training and
testing exist
let's save this and in our terminal I
will regenerate the features
refresh the page and now we have this
zero one here as expected I won't be
using this input so much anymore so I'm
going to disable it by default
in viewer HTML under the sketch pad
we will say toggle input so now if I
save and refresh the page
it's off
and if we look for erminho here
and click on his house
something weird happens
I think we have an error
and it wants to display it on this chart
with an image for that label
which we don't have so let's go to utils
in common
and I can't write here an attribute with
the question mark but I can using this
other syntax
so I will
will have a red
question mark emoji
here now let's refresh click on the
house again
and there's no error but
where is the house on the chart
it's actually where it should be I'm
gonna zoom out
and it's there normalizing doesn't
guarantee that your result will be in
the 0 1 range but most of the time it is
there especially if you have a large
training set like if I'm gonna click on
any of the others here is probably going
to be there
next what we'll do is classify all these
unknown points at once
I'm gonna go to viewer HTML
and all the way at the top here
where we don't know the label we try to
find it out using our classify function
we classify the test sample
point I'm de-structuring here because
the nearest samples also come with it
and then I'm going to set the test label
to whatever comes from there
and I'm also going to set here an
attribute for correct which comes after
comparing this label with the truth
value from earlier this will be useful
when displaying the items I want to use
a different color let's go to JS display
Js
up in this create row function when we
de-structure here properties of the
sample let's add this correct attribute
as well and here where we are creating
our sample container I'm going to check
if it's correct and if it is
I'm going to style
its background
so it's light green
let's save this refresh
and look at this
presumably this is where our test set
starts can't be sure because this could
also be part of the test set with all of
them wrong but I remember it was this
one
to be sure we should add a subtitle here
let's go to viewer HTML
between these two
pieces of code I'm going to write
subtitle
creating an H2 tag
with an inner HTML of testing
I will add this to the container as well
let's save this refresh and now it's
clear where it starts
now if we click on some of these
they don't turn yellow anymore if they
are these green ones so we can fix that
by going to style CSS
inside of this emphasize we can add here
unimportant
like this this will make it appear even
on top of this green color
now I'm not going to count how many of
these things are green instead I'm going
to calculate an accuracy we'll go to
viewer HTML
and in the control panel after this
toggle input button let's have a
statistics field I'll just use a div for
that and in it we'll put some numbers
that we calculate here
I'm going to count how many times we are
correct and how many times we have in
total
and here
I will just update the total count by
one at each time
and our correct count will grow
depending on this correct value if it is
correct it grows by one otherwise it
doesn't grow then below this I'm going
to
put inside of the statistics div and
inner HTML starting with the Bold
accuracy and then a new line where we
are going to concatenate the correct
count slash the total count and I'm also
going to put in parenthesis
the percentage
we have a function for that in utils
already
like so let's save this refresh and here
is our number it could be bigger even on
my small testing page here let's go to
style CSS at the bottom
and add the field for these statistics
increasing the size and adding some
padding
okay so
39.62 that's our accuracy
when we
use our K nearest neighbor classifier
where the 10 nearest neighbors are
considered but this is really a
parameter
and now we can compare
if we extract it as k
and move it up here at the top
and set it to one let's see what the
accuracy was without
using multiple Neighbors
it was actually much worse so
considering multiple neighbors was
indeed a good idea now we can say for
sure
let's try some other value Maybe 50.
wow we got 43.6 almost 50 percent with
just these two basic features
let's see how this
input spider
looks now with 50 lines here
creepy
we can see it better if we change the
color to Black for those lines
in chart
Js
let's set here
CTX
stroke Style
I think gray is enough
I don't know why I like this so much
this accuracy is not amazing but we're
on the right track it's much better than
guessing
or is it what is the probability to
guess correctly can you figure it out
try also implementing a classifier that
just guesses and empirically test to see
if you were right
also there's a lot of duplicated code
and feature extractor.js and viewer HTML
can you find a better structure for it
share it with me I'll choose my favorite
and refactor the code in that way
decision boundaries are a useful way to
understand the classifier I'll show you
how to generate decision boundary plots
and how to display them on our chart
now this spider is cool but it's not
very informative
I mean to figure out why this is a house
you would need to count all of these
different things and not very useful
really
we can get more information from
something called the decision boundary
plot and I'll teach you how to get to
that but first we need to refactor some
of this code so we can do this
evaluation
also in our node environment
let me close some of these things here
and in our node folder I'll create a new
file run evaluation
JS and let's begin by loading our
constants
and our utils I'm just going to copy
this and say utils
now we're going to create a place to
hold our classifiers
like our
k n classifier
will be in common
classifiers
KN and JS let's pretend we have it for
now and just see what we would do with
it if it was there sometimes it's good
to think like that
let's access the file system
and I'll put a log here for running
classification
first thing we need for classification
is to get a hold of our training samples
I'm just parsing the data in our
training
Json file and I'm calling it training
samples what we would do next is
instantiate our K nearest neighbor
classifier as a new k n
on the training samples
and a value of K maybe 50. that's all we
need then we test
we get our testing samples
from the other
Json file
like this and compute the accuracy
similar as what we did on the web page I
am going to initialize total count and
correct count
and go through all the samples
of the testing samples
and for each of them I'm going to want
to predict
what the label is
by calling k n predict
given this
testing sample point
the correct count will increase
if it's a correct prediction
and the total count regardless
then let's log in the console similar is
on the web page the accuracy column and
then
concatenate with
correct count total count
and format the percent
using our utility function
in parenthesis
okay that's all we want in this file but
now let's implement this k n class
we'll do it in common and here we need
to create a new folder
for classifiers eventually we'll have
more than just the K nearest neighbor in
it we create a new file KN JS and start
defining our class
Constructor will take some samples and
okay
it will store them
and the k
and we predict a given point
to implement this I'm just going to take
the code from viewer HTML
the one for our classification
paste it here
and fix a few things this training
samples now is this samples in both
these places so here and here
K is also this k
so I need to be careful with that
otherwise we're fine this is called
point in both places
but the return is different
we are not returning just a label but
also the nearest samples it could be
useful to have both of them maybe even
more data sometimes like probabilities
so I'll keep this as such and change our
run evaluation script accordingly by
destructuring here
label
as predicted label
like so now we also need to remember in
kn.js
to go down and Export this object
we will use it also in the web
so we need to check if module is
existing there
and it uses from utils get nearest
because of that we have to require utils
here and because we use it on the web
I'm also going to check if utils doesn't
already exist
now in the terminal we will type node
run evaluation.js
and we get an accuracy
same as we did on the web page no
surprise there
let's update the web page to use this
new code that we wrote
I'm going to copy this
and include
the k n classifier
and below here I will
instantiate it
using the training samples
and K
now here instead of classify we can just
ask KNN to predict
this point
and the same thing below
for the sketch pad
and we can remove this classify function
completely
let's refresh the page
and everything still works as before but
now the code is only in one place and we
don't make silly mistakes like changing
one thing in one and forgetting about
the other
refactoring like this is really
important
now we can go to this run evaluation
after printing the accuracy here and
I'll teach you how to generate a
decision boundary plot
let's log that we are starting to do
that
and we'll need to use a canvas
we use the create canvas function to
generate a canvas of 100 times 100
and let's get an access to the
to the drawing context and use it to
draw our plot it will be a pixel based
plot where we take each individual pixel
of this canvas and treat it as a feature
between 0 and 1 will normalize it and
then we will color the pixel depending
on the predicted value you'll see
we Loop first on the x-axis pixel by
pixel
and the same on this y-axis
and let's create a normalized point here
a point which will have the X component
x divided by this canvas width
and the Y component is y divided by the
canvas height but we put a 1 minus that
because eventually we'll put this plot
on our chart here and it should start
from the bottom and go upwards otherwise
it will be flipped like that
now let's get the label
from predicting the point and choose a
caller
from our Styles in utils according to
this label
like so now we can set the fill Style
to this color and draw a small rectangle
at The X Y location with one and one
width and height like one pixel I'm
gonna close this
and write this image
into a file using a buffer it's going to
be a PNG image
we write it
in a place where we need to define the
constant for
and let's log here that we are done we
just need to add this constant next
so constants
I'll put it here at the end
the decision boundary
will be in our data set directory
decision boundary dot PNG save the file
return to our terminal
and rerun the evaluation
you can see this decision boundary takes
some time
and it's done we can see it here in the
data data set decision boundary
and visual studio code can open it here
as well it's a small image it's 100
times 100 pixels generating larger is
possible but it will take a long time
so we'll work with this for now and I'll
show you higher resolution once later we
now set this image as the background of
our chart
we go to viewer HTML
where we Define our chart options here
and let's Implement a new option which
will be
for the background BG
it will be a new image and I'm going to
set its source
to be that of the decision boundary plot
our chart doesn't support this
background yet
so I'm going to chart
Js
to implement this feature
I'm going to take the background image
out of the options here store it as an
attribute
and in our draw method before drawing
the samples here I'm going to plot the
image
I will first take the top left
coordinate according to the data it's
the zero one point essentially but we
have to get the pixel value for it so
from the data bounds to the pixel bounds
we can put here 0 1 and the size of this
image is going to be the size of the
chart minus the margin on both sides
and then we have to also divide this
according to how the transformation was
done how the scaling was done using the
second power
and then finally we can draw this
background at the top left location
we can spread this out like so and then
size size for the width and height it's
a square aspect ratio
let's save this
open the page and it actually works the
image will appear here as soon as my
mouse will hover it I'm not waiting for
the image to load so hovering here
redraws the chart after it has loaded
and I'm fine with this you can see there
are different colors on the background
now and they correspond to our samples
but zooming in this image is really low
resolution so we could do with a better
one
also this smoothing effect that happens
here can be disturbing a bit we can
remove it actually if we go to the Chart
Constructor
after we get a hold of this context we
can tell it to
disable the smoothing
by setting it
to false
let's save this refresh
and now you can see these pixels here
sharp but to understand things better
we'll need to look at an image with a
higher resolution
and I've computed one in a few hours
it's 5000 by 5000 and it looks like this
and what it means is that actually we
don't need to show the data anymore
like if I'm gonna go here in the draw
method
and comment out drawing the samples
actually I think we can be without many
things here we don't need the samples or
the hovered sample or the selected
sample anymore
and here we don't need this part even
we just need to see where the point is
let's refresh and if I'm going to open
this input and sketch something here
you can see the point here on the plot
and it's a fish because it's in the red
area but if this would go higher
it would instantly change to a bicycle
then to a clock
and then let's see closer
quite complex structure here reminds me
of fractals or land masses you could use
this as a Terrain generator
now let's go even higher
so there is a house
and then it's a tree
and so on much clearer in this way we
don't need to count how many nearest
neighbors there are how many labels and
and so on
these colored regions tell us and it's
really interesting to look at how these
different regions appear
let me show you one for when K is set to
1.
very different isn't it
to understand better let me add the
points again and now let's zoom in a bit
you can see this green patch here every
Point inside it is closest to this tree
and this is the separating border
between the tree and this pencil if you
know what the voronoi is then these
edges here are a subset of that
and if we go inside the data where it's
more complex you can really see this
pattern each of the training samples are
in their own little region
sometimes multiple points make a bigger
region like this
all right you now know about feature
extraction data scaling classification
and evaluation and you have a lot of
tools under your belt your task if you
choose to accept it is to calculate the
accuracy for all possible values of K
and create a line chart conclude what
the best value is and generate a high
resolution decision boundary plot for it
as well
share these charts with me and I'll
showcase the first correct answer in a
future video
let's review what we learned so far
using Python and the scikit-learn
library
install these now to follow along
but first we still do a bit of
JavaScript to prepare the data for
python
in JavaScript we use Json a lot
like here where we are writing our
features
it's possible to do this also in Python
but more common there is to use CSV
files
so let's go to utilsjs
and Implement a function to convert our
samples to CSV format
let's call it to CSV and it will take us
parameters the headers of the data the
name of the features and the samples
array
it will output a string
and let's initialize this with the
headers separated by comma and then a
new line like this we then Loop through
all the samples
and we do the same thing for each sample
separating the feature values by a comma
as well and the new line at the end
let's return this string
save the file and then feature
extractor.js
let's go where we are writing the
training data and write a new code for
outputting it in CSV form
we write the file
and we'll have a separate constant for
the CSV file
we output the CSV our feature names but
also the label notice here I'm sending
the first parameter a concatenation
between the feature names and the label
so it will have three columns not just
two
and similarly the second parameter I'm
going to remap training
to contain the point
and the label of that point let's close
this copy this and do the same thing for
testing as well
where we're writing the testing Json
file beneath it I'm going to paste this
and rename to testing CSV
and training here to testing
as well now save the file and let's
define these CSV constants
I'm just going to copy this training and
testing Json constants from here
below and rename this to training CSV
testing
CSV
and the extensions here will be
CSV and CSV
let's save the file and in our terminal
now we can
run our feature extractor again
and if we look in the data
data set
two new files have appeared testing CSV
training.csv and if we open them they
look like this
this kind of format is very common when
working in Python
actually even more common would be to
replace here the label names with the
number an index for the label but we'll
leave it like this
now let me close these from here and
let's start working with python to do
that I'm going to create a new folder
Python and inside this folder I will
create the file called
knnn.py we'll re-implement the K nearest
neighbor in Python this time using
libraries We Begin by opening the
training
CSV file from data
for reading let's read the lines
and let's print to see what form we get
this in I'm going to be testing in the
terminal
let me go out of this node folder and
inside the python directory and let's
run this script by typing python
okay and then dot p y and we get this
array where each item is a row
represented as a string the new line
character is also there let's check to
see how long this array is
yeah that looks about right
now let's parse this data in a more
usable format
it's common to refer to the data as
capital X in Python like this and for
the labels as y
these are two empty arrays and we're
gonna populate them by looping through
our lines but I'm going to start at 1
because I want to skip the headers
like so now we are going to split by the
comma
and start appending values into X we're
going to append an array with the
feature values so we'll exclude the last
entry here which is the label we also
have to convert these values into Float
by default their strings
so we can write
float conversion of the row of J
4J in range
the length of the row minus one we can
close this and then to the Y we append
the label the last value in this row
after the split but as I mentioned
previously it's more useful to have
these as numbers so I'm going to remap
these
using a classes object you'll see of the
row of
-1 this is a quick way to refer to the
last item in Python so this classes here
is going to be an object that I'm going
to Define here at the top and it's just
gonna say that for car use a value of 0
for fish you use a value of one for our
house use a value of two
for tree bicycle four
guitar five
pencil six and the clock
seven
in Python objects like this are called
the dictionaries now if I'm going to
save this and rerun the script we get an
error here because car comes with a
backslash n at the end so so let's fix
this by stripping this string here
it removes white space let's save
restart the script and no errors this
time but we just get the print from
earlier let's remove this and print
something else maybe we can print the
value of the X array but we could just
print the first 10 items like this so we
don't overload the terminal
let's save this
restart
and this is what we get
if we look in the data to compare in the
data set training CSV they do seem to
match with the first 10 values from here
let's print also the Y value here
save
restart the script
and these look good as well going from
car to clock which is a 7 and then back
to zero one and so on
now let's remove this and do our K
nearest neighbor classification I will
import
from the scikit-learn
Neighbors
the K neighbors classifier and
instantiate this
like so
where we can pass how many neighbors we
want to use
in the web app we used 50 so let's set
here and Neighbors
250 and there are many possible
parameters here for all kind of variants
but to get similar Behavior as in our
web app I'm going to pass the Brute
Force algorithm
and uniform weights
we can then fit our data to this KNN
object and start testing it's really
that easy
but we need to read the testing data as
well and instead of just writing this
all over again I'm going to extract this
as a function let's call this
read feature file
given a file path like this let's rename
this with the file path
and indent everything inside indentation
in Python is very important
and return here a tuple with X and Y
now here
we can read our training data
using the new function
so we have the X and Y to pass to the
fit
and
read the testing data
next
I'm gonna store in the same variables
here
we can then calculate the accuracy of
our model with score
of X and Y
and let's print it
in the terminal I'm going to save this
re-run the script
and there it is
python can do much more than this try
installing matplotlib and use it to
display the feature values try
customizing it the way you want
can you make it display the decision
boundaries as well
share your code with me and I'll
showcase it in a future video
now the course will take a short break
meanwhile do your homework and reflect
on what you learned next time we start
Phase 2 where we bring the accuracy to a
whole new level
see you guys